NATALIE VILLALOBOS: I don't
want to add too much to the day,
to Pavni's wise words, to
the amazing fireside chat
that we had.
But I didn't want
to say thank you.
So as we mentioned
before, Women Techmakers,
we provide
visibility, community,
and resources for
Women in Technology,
and that's really to drive
innovation and participation
in the field of technology.
And some of you might have
a technical background.
I don't.
I'm a history major.
But I'm on a path to just
understanding all the ways
that I can participate
in this industry.
I actually think that if I were
to pursue a new line of work,
I think I'd want
to be a designer.
And so I'm really excited
that there were so many of you
in here that participated
in the design sprint.
And I popped over
to the code lab
that was being led
by Wayne and team,
and that seemed really awesome.
I'm already retweeting and
favoriting a lot of the watch
faces that you've developed.
So I'm just really thankful
and excited that you showed up,
and I say that because
you create a party,
and then you still worry if
people will come, so thank you.
And so I want to just take
this moment to say some of you
were here last year,
and we took a lot
of your feedback to make
the event even better
for this year.
When it comes to
next year's event,
we want to hear your feedback.
So please, share
your ideas with us.
You can email me directly.
I'm just
women-techmakers@google.com.
I answer all the emails.
And we have our Twitter handle
that we launched this week
that's @WomenTechmakers.
And share your thoughts, your
ideas, your inspirations,
your favorite photos
with our hashtag.
And again, let's have
a round of applause
for all of our
instructors, TAs, speakers.
They're amazing.
[APPLAUSE]
The volunteers that created
this event-- there are many.
And I know that we're all
sitting here in Mountain View,
and we're thinking, oh,
there's about 300 of us.
And are we it?
Is this it?
And no.
So we actually have
13 global summits
that are happening in
the month of March.
Singapore happened
a couple days ago,
and then we had Mexico City.
Today was also New York.
And then as you're seeing
in the tent social feed,
we also have many events.
We recognize we don't have
Google offices everywhere,
so we have some hyperlocal
events, about 100 of them,
that are happening around
the world from mainland China
to Africa to Latin
America to Canada
to Russia-- like,
everywhere, right?
So when you're looking
at the social media feed,
you're going to see so many
voices around the world.
And we did that
intentionally to let you
know that you are a part
of a global movement.
You're not alone
in those moments
when you're being self critical.
You literally have a community
of tens of thousands,
if not hundreds of thousands
of people, to help you,
to support you, to cheer you on.
And this whole team and all
the speakers and instructors
are on that team to support you.
So with that, I
want to invite us
all to our outdoor reception.
Pavni is going to be around,
as well as all of us.
If you have questions or
ideas, please let us know.
And thank you, and
come back next year.
[APPLAUSE]